- Hey guys, we're incredibly lucky today
to have Dr. Anthony
Fauci, who's the director
of the Allergy and Infectious
Disease branch of the NIH.
You may have seen him on stage with Trump
as he's part of the
Coronavirus Task Force.
He's gonna be answering
some of our questions today.
Let's get right to it!
- Dr. Mike, how are you?
- How's is going?
- Runnin' around like a maniac here,
but other than that, I'm good!
- I can only imagine.
I heard your wife was forcing you to get
at least four or five hours of sleep.
I'm proud of her for doing that.
- Yes, four hours is all I'm doing,
but she's the one that's doin' it!
She's the one that's doin' it.
- (laughs) All right, fair enough.
Well, first of all, let
me say a huge thank you
for joining us on the YouTube channel.
Everyone in the YouTube community
really appreciates what you're doing.
My whole channel is about fact-checking,
putting out accurate info,
and you've essentially
become the face for that.
So huge thanks from all of us for that.
- My pleasure.
- Let's start by talking
about social distancing.
It's something that I've explained
to my audience that's
incredibly important,
that's how we control
the spread of this virus,
the run on hospitals.
There's been a lot of talk
recently about curtailing that.
I'm curious not so much about the date,
because as you've said, the
virus doesn't have a timeline.
What is the yardstick
that we're gonna be using
to measure when it may be safe
to curtail the social distancing?
Is it number of those who are ill,
fatalities, hospital
preparedness, what say you?
- Well, it's a combination of things
and it's gonna be different
through different regions of the country.
Because you can't look
at it as unidimensional.
I mean, New York is clearly
different from Washington,
and it's clearly different from Alabama.
But in direct answer to your question,
you look at two things.
You look at the kinetics of the outbreak
when you're in the middle of an outbreak.
So once it starts reaching that point
of plateauing a bit and coming down,
you don't wanna stop
the social distancing,
but you may be able to
relieve the restrictions
on movement in order to get
basic supplies to people,
so that they're not just locked down.
If you have an area
that has very few cases,
what you wanna do is you
wanna test a lot in that area
to get a feel for what the
penetrance of the virus is.
And when you get an individual case,
you want to immediately
identify it, isolate it,
contact trace it, and
get it out of society.
If you do that efficiently,
you may be able to open up that community,
because you're doing good containment.
You know, the two major
pillars are containment,
where you try to stop the spread,
and the other is mitigation, when you say,
"Oh my goodness, it's here.
"What are we gonna do to
prevent it from getting worse?"
- Do you think that there would be any
conditions where you think politicians
may act too soon and start saying,
"Let's start opening up
some of these restrictions"?
What would happen in a red
alert type scenario like that?
- Well, I think that would be unfortunate,
and that's the thing
that we advise against.
If you do open up too soon,
you could have the perverse effect
that as it's going this way,
then it starts going back up.
And then you essentially compound the need
for the kind of things,
respirators, ventilators,
hospital beds, ICU, things like that.
- You've talked a little
bit about seasonality,
the possibility that this virus
may go away for the summer,
may return in the fall,
certainly not a definite.
But if that were to
happen, what preparations
can we take as ordinary
citizens for the fall,
and myself, as someone
who's on the front lines
as a family medicine
doctor, what can we do?
- Okay, first of all, if that happens,
and to be honest with you, I
think it's going to happen,
I really don't see something
as robustly transmitted as this
disappearing the way SARS did.
Particularly, if we
start to see an increase
in infections in the Southern Hemisphere,
southern Africa, places like that,
now, as they enter their winter.
Which means for sure,
a cycle will come back.
That means that as we
go down in our cases,
we've gonna use that time to prepare
that it doesn't happen to us to the extent
that it did the first time around.
That's why we've got to do the vaccine
development that we're doing,
we've gotta do clinical trials in drugs,
randomized controlled trials
that prove things work,
as opposed to maybe they're gonna work.
Those are the things that we need to do,
as well as get the kind
of testing capabilities
so that you can do good containment,
without waiting until
it gets into mitigation.
We may have a window, and
it's not gonna be over.
We're gonna breathe a sigh of relief
when it starts to go down,
but we need to gird ourselves
that it may come back.
- You mentioned the clinical trials.
There's hundreds of clinical
trials going on right now
testing all sorts of
combinations, remdesivir,
hydroxychloroquine, even
plasma transfusions,
are all on the table.
I know that we don't have any randomized
controlled results yet.
Do you have a medication or a treatment
that you think is a
front-runner at this time?
- Well, you know, we
have a remdesivir trial
that we do have a
randomized controlled trial.
And I would hope that within the next
couple of months or less,
and I would say "or less,"
we're either gonna get an efficacy signal,
then we could say, "Well, let's do it,
"let's let it rip with that drug,"
or we're gonna get nothing!
And then we'll say, "Get it off the table
"and stop wasting time!"
- Sure.
- But I think that's
gonna be reasonably soon.
And also, the plasma
transfusions, immune globulin,
those kinds of things,
monoclonal antibodies,
they're all gonna be going into testing.
- Okay, what I meant
about the randomized controlled studies,
that we don't have the
results to those studies yet,
because that's why it's difficult to pick
a front-runner.
- We don't have the results.
The N is not big enough yet.
When we get a big enough N, we'll know.
- Absolutely, we need them powered.
Young people, they seem
to be more affected,
or at least that's what the media
is telling us here in the United States.
Is that true, and if so,
why here more than in China?
- That's a good question.
Everybody knows that
the original China data
made it look like young people virtually
never got involved in a serious way.
Then as we start getting into Italy,
looking a little bit more like us, France,
European countries and ourselves,
we're starting to see
individuals in their 30s and 40s.
Now if you look at them, still,
many of them have underlying conditions,
even though they're 30 or 40.
They have diabetes,
they have hypertension,
they have things like that.
But if you look closely, you will see
that there are young people,
who are otherwise well,
who can get seriously ill.
So we need to forget this,
that if you're young,
you're good to go, you have no problem.
There are two issues with younger people
you need to consider.
A, you need to avoid infection,
just like everybody else,
not only for your own health,
but even if you get trivially involved,
you can be a vector that would
ultimately infect someone
who does have a real risk
of serious conditions.
It's kind of like the
young healthy 25-year-old
gets infected, goes home,
infects Grandma and Grandpa,
or a 40-year-old uncle
who has metastatic disease
on chemotherapy, that's the problem!
- There's been some talk
about the possibility
of reinfection with COVID-19.
Now do you think that this is
more an issue with testing,
that the test remains
positive, or are they truly
being infected for a
second time with the virus?
- I don't know the answer to that 100%
but I would be willing
to bet on my experience,
and I'll bet your experience, (chuckles)
that any virus that you
have, if you do well,
recover, and clear the virus,
if it acts like any other virus,
you're gonna have lasting immunity.
You're not gonna get
reinfected, you're just not.
- The way that I've thought about it is,
there's certain illnesses where
you get lifelong immunity,
chicken pox, measles with
your two vaccinations,
so maybe this won't be lifelong immunity,
but to say there's none,
where you can get reinfected
in two weeks, something seems off.
- No, that's inconceivable
to me that that's the case.
I mean, you're gonna have some
degree of durable immunity.
You're right, it may not be 50 years,
but it's certainly gonna be a matter
of a few years, right.
- Sure.
For myself as a healthcare
provider, this is something
my hospital system even
asked me to ask you.
When is it safe for us to return to work,
once we've either tested
positive for COVID-19,
or you know, with the
lack of testing kits,
had a upper respiratory viral illness,
where we don't know if it was
COVID-19, when can we return?
Is it when fever subsides, 24
hours after fever subsides,
or do we do a full 14-day
or 21-day quarantine?
- If you are a healthcare provider
or someone who is in a
critical infrastructure
and you need to get back to work,
to assume that you're infected,
what you can do is that
you can wear a mask,
take your temperature
daily, monitor yourself.
If you get symptoms,
get outta circulation!
If not, assume you're infected,
but do it in a way where you
don't infect anybody else.
Otherwise, every one of
our health care providers
are getting exposed every day.
- Of course.
- They can't assume
they're infected, they've
just gotta go to work,
and that's one of the things
we're gonna be recommending.
- Makes sense, that brings me to the topic
of personal protective
equipment, N95 masks.
As recently as last week,
my hospital was in need
of these donations.
I actually went on a journey to purchase
$50,000 worth of masks, myself,
from construction workers,
and was able to donate them.
Why do you think there's such a shortage?
Obviously, there's huge demand,
because we need to constantly
be using these masks.
New York Presbyterian Hospital system,
they use 40,000 to 70,000 masks a day.
But do you also think there's an issue
of hoarding here, or some
sort of customs issue
of getting these masks shipped over?
- It's a combination of all of the above.
So one of the things that
we've really gotta get
away from was, we gotta
bake testing in a way
that doesn't have the tester consume PPE!
PPE should be for the people
who are taking care of sick patients.
And right now, we've gotta have a system
where a person can self-stick the swab in,
put it in the vial, give it to somebody,
and nobody puts PPE on!
So you don't waste it,
that's the first thing.
The second thing, we've
gotta keep manufacturing it
at a very, very high level!
I mean, there was no anticipation
that so many people would need this.
So we've gotta get people who
don't need it to not use it,
and we gotta get a lot more
for the people who need it.
- Speaking of those
types of quick testing,
for point-of-care testing,
for those rapid tests,
do you see that coming
sooner rather than later?
For us in the family practice setting,
we have the influenza swabs,
that in 15 minutes we have an answer.
Is there something like
that on the horizon?
- Yeah, I mean, I go to
these Task Force meetings
at the White House every day.
I was at one last evening.
That was a topic of conversation.
How are we gonna scale these
up and get these going?
I can't give you a timeframe,
but there's a lot of enthusiasm
about getting the private
sector to really scale that up.
- America and Italy seem
to be disproportionately
affected to other nations
that are even closer
to Wuhan, China, which
seems to be the epicenter,
or the original epicenter of this virus.
Why do you think that this happened here
in the U.S. and in Italy so
much so than other nations?
- Well, I think because people travel here
and travel to Europe and Italy a lot.
I think we really saved
ourselves a real bad
bullet, if you wanna call that,
by very quickly shutting down
the influx of cases from China,
and then something that
was very controversial,
you might remember, when we
shut down influx from Europe,
because Europe is the new China.
There's some numbers
that you may be aware of,
that are really extraordinary.
About 60% of all the infections now,
if you talk about New York
City, how we're getting influx
from other countries, particularly China,
that's how New York got hit so badly.
New York, I mean,
I'm a New Yorker, in case you
haven't figured that out--
- Same!
- From my accent. (laughs)
But you know, about 56%
of the new infections
right now in our country
are in New York City.
New York City has more
than half of the action.
It's a big city, it's a robust
city, people come and go.
I think that's the reason
why the United States
is getting hit, because
the kind of country we are.
- It makes sense, and you know,
I live a few blocks
away from Times Square,
my windows actually look at Times Square,
and I think there's also a statement,
something to celebrate,
the fact that there's so much solidarity.
This past Saturday, nine p.m.,
there wasn't a soul in Times Square.
The fact that we are coming together
and doing the social distancing
is not something talked about in media,
and I think it should be highlighted.
We are doing a good job,
especially under these
crazy circumstances.
Would you agree?
- I totally agree, I was gonna say,
"I am amazed," but that's the wrong word.
I am impressed, yeah--
- Proud.
- I shouldn't be amazed,
I shouldn't be amazed,
because the American spirit is amazing.
But in fact, what I see here
in Washington, D.C. is the same thing.
I mean, people are doing things
in a calm way that I
just think is wonderful.
- For sure.
- It really is, really is.
- Agreed, and my final question is,
any guidance for us as physicians,
and what role do you think it plays
in filling out death certificates?
I've filled these out
before for my patients
when I have done death
pronouncements as a resident.
If a patient has CHF, they
come in with a congestive
heart failure exacerbation but they also
have a viral illness at the time,
what should go on the death certificate
as a clinical judgment,
and what role do you think
that plays in the numbers?
- I think it's gonna
influence the numbers.
I think you've gotta make it clear.
If someone obviously
goes into it with acute
respiratory distress syndrome
and dies on a ventilator,
that's coronavirus disease! (laughs)
You gotta make sure it gets
onto the death certificate.
- Okay.
Yeah, 'cause I've seen
countries that have been
having low numbers of COVID-19 mortality,
but then their numbers
of pneumonia cases spike,
and it's, are you just changing
what's on the death certificate there,
and that's impacting those numbers?
- Right, right.
- All right, well, thank you so much,
Dr. Fauci, very much appreciate your time
and everything you've done for our nation.
You're a voice of reason
in a much-needed time.
- Thank you, it's very much
of a pleasure to be with you.
Keep up your good work!
- Thank you.
- In the trenches is
important, keep it up!
- Dr. Fauci's amazing at fact-checking,
especially presidents;
he's served six of them.
Now, I tried my hand at
fact-checking politicians.
Click on the video here.
Or if you wanna have a
good laugh, click here.
(upbeat music)